il y eut le temps de la souffrance et
puis vint le temps des communautés des
lieux de pureté ou le chaos est devenu
harmonie
tu sais piloter ces engins bien sûr ça
t'arrive d'aller jusqu'à la frontière
ouais et après il ya quoi je ne sais
rien on n'a pas le droit d'aller au delà
si on allait voir la loi l'interdît
bonjour je m'appelle sais qui tu es qui
êtes-vous
le passeur quand le conseil a besoin
d'être guidé je lui procure de la
sagesse en puisant dans le passé du
temps où il y avait bien plus bien plus
aujourd'hui rouge tu finiras par tous
voir toutes les couleurs toutes les
différences ce sont les injections
quotidiennes qu'ils y font disparaître
quand les gens ont la possibilité de
choisir
ils font le mauvais choix entre les
apparences et la réalité il ya un monde
regarde c'est mon père
il a tué les jeunes comme les anciens
sont tués pour le bien-être commun il ya
des choses que tu ne sais pas qui me
fait peur ça fait des mois que j'ai
arrêté
qu'est ce que tu ressens jonas est
devenu une menace
il faudrait leur ouvrir les yeux tu peux
agir
tu peux changer le cours des choses
tu va l'affronter
et nous en débarrasser